citizens to the reject Nation it is time to
shh that means we're watching hush Mike Flanagan
2016 hush it's what really put him on the
map before all those TV shows that we know
and love uh it's Ron joxie today Jay oh you
broke my valve silence just then Ron jocks
he's back in the hot seat yeah you can't be
silent when you're on jaxy and nah dude not
when you're dropping boys back in the building
100 true I hope you like this movie I hope
we like this movie it's supposed to be a good
one and Mike is my my guy I'm a I'm a Mikey
gal so I'm a flanigai so much cooler than
mine yeah they're they're eager leave a comment
like subscribe let us know if you are hushed
throughout this whole thing actually don't
be hushed right things be vocal with us because
that's the point of a reaction okay okay yeah
what what are you little John right now that's
my role for this whole reaction I'll be making
three comments great I hope you're hushed
the entire time except for that oh except
for the fact that you're gonna be a Comic-Con
that is that is a fact we are Saturday we
got a panel Saturday afternoon 1 p.m red coin
is gonna be fun maybe even a Roxy appearance
you know I might stop by we're on some kind
of cat years who knows why and don't forget
also to go over to patreon if you want to
see more of us you want to see more of the
video the whole thing then you can be a super
sexy reject all right should we do it let's
do it [Music]
what's your prediction for how long it's silent
in this movie it's an excellent question give
it 10 minutes
well I lost the bet Roxy walked right into
that one I'm just gonna say 45 minutes you
would have won
it's a lovely Cabin in the Woods I wonder
how many people rented this we're like something's
wrong making a feast how much for a rib one
rib
so this is the first we saw her before Hill
House might be they're married you know are
they really yeah
cool way of showing that she's deaf that's
a nice perspective switch
gosh I'm supposed to respond to her [__]
I said waiting on John so
it's often what people text about me I actually
love that she's in there as Sarah next door
it's how real people save people's numbers
yeah
oh who's that
there's a cat yeah that's a forest neighborhood
cat it's a wild cat yeah she's doing a service
all right it could be out there devouring
someone's puggle right now
foreshadowing oh that's a I don't know but
I know I know her we'll figure it out comment
below another Triple H situation she's a wrestler
yes getting warmer I finished your book I
know you can read my lips but I'm getting
better better I want to practice taking another
class with John it's fun and we're better
at understanding than actually doing it it's
true I can vouch for them I tried to guess
the ending I'm usually on point with that
sort of thing but I was way off I'm always
on point that sort of thing
makes me crazy foreshadowing
I find like the right ending to connect to
the right story does the voice sound like
a kid you were 13 when you got sick I think
they say 50 of us think in voice yeah and
certain people don't have an internal yeah
I think that you are a good Storyteller she's
in his Mike's other stuff that's how I know
her
[Laughter] [Music] those are very different
yeah I was gonna say you left all that stuff
cooking
oh boy not the cat this things rattle your
brains
yeah it's like a burglar alarm
well I imagine that would wake anybody yeah
that's handy Jesus though how much sound that
must be I was in The Miracle Worker in high
school and they we took some sign language
oh yeah yeah remember any of it a little bit
because it's the most beautiful language of
all time truly oh who's Craig someone who's
thinking of her obviously dude and hey she's
got so many friends reading that book I do
not think Craig's a good guy I think you're
misreading that Craig there's a reason she
deleted it yeah because he's just too good
now she can't live up to that yeah why put
yourself through that you know so it works
you're right that's what makes us women's
right he's not gonna kick the door in by the
end of the movie the next Midnight Mass Easter
eggs oh my God wait so is this before so is
midnight mass oh it's way before midnight
mass because it's 2016. midnight mass was
during the pandemic I think so and before
that was Haunting of Hill House and blind
Manor yeah is midnight mass like canonically
supposed to be based on this book is she a
writer of monologues I don't know but Mike
Flanagan's the IT guy dude it's Andy muschietti
actually because he directed it oh but I know
what you meant I was like I know it's just
being a horror goof on you do I have it I'm
sorry I wasn't listening what the church to
Aaron the church to Father Paul bring in Aaron's
the rage bubbled up spreading into his head
his ears ring his eyes felt hot whose voice
do you think she hears she said it sounds
like her mother that's better he needs something
more something's okay better Aaron dies can't
kill Aaron oh piss him all off didn't set
it up this is a great internal monologue this
is very real call Craig which Craig is going
to be it's Craig Robinson
you know boy oh no he got a ring that's worse
you did you let it ring through twice girl
dude don't you oh okay okay no no no babe
dude you're trapped no no you hate to see
it
you never yeah
no no no no
[Music] and that's the last we'll hear of
Craig
this is a perfectly good sauce concoction
is it looks like a gravy of some kind yeah
knock on the door she's not gonna eat anything
oh [Music]
Jesus punch through yeah that's glass Howie
whoa is it an arrow
bummer I feel like vibrations ouch
oh God it's like a Scream movie
this feels like a ghost-facy kind of kid that
mask is really creepy yeah sometimes the masks
in these movies look goofy to me this one
does not look goofy it's a fine art the iconic
horror mask or the creepy horror mask
pick up maybe he'll see something huh uh I
got the Flash and I'll come back later
[Music]
[Laughter] huh
it
brilliant [Music] oh shazbear hey squish
did you talk to him it's been a year mom keeps
asking when you're getting back out there
she wants grandchildren look at you
it's not good for anyone to be alone squish
no who is that oh damn behind you thought
I saw something move
[__] [__] ass cat interview I wonder
how the deaf Community feels about her signage
I know that she's obviously not a deaf actress
I'm curious the reception this movie had yeah
she's doing a great job for my eyes but I
don't know and how much Super powerfication
will there be what's that well you know just
like how much are they gonna make it some
kind of like super power oh oh yeah well I
mean she didn't notice him at the door so
I don't think much yeah she clearly didn't
get like super sight yeah that like I can
sense any vibration in the air she's Daredevil
you never know
let's get that woozy tracking shot you're
probably able to shoot this for not that expensive
too I love these one house things that are
done well yeah creepy
[__] you think [__] is dead where
are you [__] I'm gonna say no not yet
but by the end of the movie I don't know man
maybe we live in a time where it could go
either way so here are the other characters
that we could still come and help John yes
Craig John and Craig are going to show up
[__] John Craig and [__] are all gonna
show up as like a buddy cop team
oh cause he took her phone oh [Music]
okay what are you doing this moment Burn It
Down
you message your sister and say SOS 911 help
yeah
oh geez
the game is a foot oh no
no [Music] it's like at this point she doesn't
know her bestie or her neighbor has been murdered
so also she doesn't know what like is here
to rob me is he willing to kill me
uh crossbow it feels a little bit like you're
next I wonder who's under that mask he is
like very telling eyes yeah can can you FaceTime
9-1-1 can uh damn it and if you had your phone
you could do a hotspot start guessing babe
[Music]
yeah you got the Goosebumps that's authentic
know how much a tire costs like 800 bucks
he's got nice ass tires he's slashing for
them I bet it's gonna be more than that yep
it's game time babe you can do this oh he's
gonna leave him a message
I think it's for hammer for if they find her
[Music]
won't tell didn't see face
boyfriend coming home
I was like yeah I hope so oh he's gonna show
her his face
wow
she doesn't know him okay I recognize him
too I can come in anytime I want and I can
get you anytime I want uh but I'm not going
to not until it's time when you wish you're
dead that's when I'll come inside wow nod
your head if you understand me
let me see you nudge here I'm actually really
glad they had him lose his mask yeah it was
a nice usually makes somebody less scary this
made him significantly more scary well yeah
because it's just a guy some lunatic and then
it doesn't become a game of who's under the
mask yeah it's what's that guy gonna do
get a couple [Music]
just wonder why they introduced John as a
concept though if we're not going to see him
at any point I think we've got it right especially
because what happened with Sarah right now
I'm like yeah those guys are gonna add to
the body cameras
God what a nightmare
really good simple setup to this
[Music] no no no do not look do not look
whoa all right well it looks like a jacked
up hand is that her home girl oh I food home
girls oh gross right you're right oh no
oh no don't drop the knife that is so twisted
what are you gonna do go out there now oh
why'd you leave the room because I didn't
want to see that anymore it's weird yeah it
like now it begs the question like I guess
I'd always want to keep him in my sight yeah
or would I if you didn't have sound then yes
okay let it out breathe
what no what was she just trying to see I
think she's trying to like set off the car
alarm so somebody would come
the range on those keys is really bad
nope careful what is that oh okay
oh nope careful he's right there right he
did unlock it
oh [Music] dude the Firearms right there
oh
really good with the choreography
song her phone her phone her phone that's
what her plan was when she saw that oh smart
yeah come on oh I'm dripping moist right now
it's good I knew I would have to pass the
mental oh my God yeah oh not bad
come on push what's harder
oh yeah yeah
they're coming it's all part of the game man
of course he's got it
that is so condescending
where is he sounds like he's yeah yeah okay
creeping in
a nice like split frame this is darker than
Game of Thrones I feel like maybe if I were
her I would get out of the house I don't know
that you're safer inside the house oh I think
I just gave bad advice she sensed her vibrations
especially out here it's going to be like
a noisitorium
just start jumping up and down don't don't
breathe
no that's about a blind guy this is horrifying
yeah cat Mouse man no I don't like this no
no don't don't move don't [__] move don't
oh no no no no no no no no no no no stop no
no no stop stop ugh yeah what do you do oh
yeah I shot an arrow right past her
oh who is she now running to running zigzags
to go back in the house yeah all right I'm
sorry I gave you bad advice my girl it's all
your fault I hate to sound like my grandma
but I do wish that they made this a little
brighter it's like I can't tell what is going
on
no no no no no no no no no no no feet first
are you what are you kidding me you dive out
whatever you're kidding me
no
I'm torn roof is kind of better maybe until
he gets up there no he's got arrows bro maybe
take your shoes off then you have no shoes
on other problems what's that red thing whoa
hahaha smart I mean so far she's pretty resourcing
very smart and in a way that feels relatively
plausible because she's a novelist that's
right it's her job to think of all the possible
outcomes seven it's just seven endings no
crawl up to the peak no not not be no uh do
you shoot her yeah I know I knew it I knew
it right in our IT band I knew it I knew it
I knew it
good flexibility there really good no he's
gonna climb the trellis now she but she has
one now I don't really because it's a modern
Arrow well you know the one that you can actually
pull out without jacking yourself up more
Oh I thought you said modern era like she
could get help at the hospital after class
this isn't it like 1600s yes do you know how
to use that no
what are you gonna do right now boo drop it
on his head and still do a lot of damage
oh boy come on oh come on no no no no no close
the window crank that Soldier Boy no no no
yes
learning how to do it
he's like touche not bad touche Mademoiselle
you're not gonna pray for death as quickly
as I thought
I'm sure this isn't the most of her worries
right now but I don't like her taking off
her pants near him yeah I mean if you don't
have it I'm saying it's not the most of her
worries right now but
so where are you supposed to tie like above
it below it I guess what right above it that's
what I would think right yeah but I actually
don't know how the blood flow works in your
legs
fire off a practice shot so we know that you
know how it works yeah let's do a training
montage oh that's uh his kill list 13 huh
she's trying to figure out how it works or
yeah
[Music]
yeah oh no Jesus Christ
[Music] John I knew John would come we always
show up right at the end
boyfriend
oh no
hey look on your head okay on your knees oh
this is a guy I responded to a call there's
someone inside he came running past me knocked
me cold I woke up without my phone or my radio
I need to call for backup oh no jeez can I
use your phone call for backup I should have
called it in when I first got here there you
go all right he's gonna break it doesn't have
a lock on that thing yeah I got a 719 here
at 811 Fairhope signs a possible forced entry
suspect is at large on foot what's the tell
the phone yeah of course yeah sorry so stupid
of me oh no oh no what's your habits oh what
was I must be his girlfriend's earring but
was that intentional you said you responded
to a call was that from Maddie from dispatcher
they said someone uh had called it in yeah
because she wouldn't be able to make that
call she's deaf mute stop saying your thoughts
out loud well I guess it must have been your
girlfriend then made the call I was a pretty
clumsy lie there yeah you know I can't swear
to it but yeah you know I'm pretty sure she
has a spare key in that uh planner oh no Porsche
down there no no no uh it's right down there
on that corner John actually looks familiar
too for sure trashed your car pretty good
huh oh yeah look at that geez call send a
text make a call didn't hear you said yeah
I think so I'm not sure oh no don't be too
obvious with that rock yeah you were not built
for this guy [Music] whoa I knew it knew it
easy ah damn it it's done it's done it's done
oh no
that was tough it's okay it's okay it's okay
oh
nice nice shot there my dude got this one
like horror movie I'm not quite dead jump
yeah cause he doesn't know his girlfriend's
dead either Ron can read his lips from all
the way over there
I can only stumble
no no wow [Music]
this is the image that she's having one of
the endings yeah she's playing them out in
her head this isn't real [Music] you can't
run yeah
yeah work it out like a story take control
the narrative
oh no I would have maybe tried to go out there
and kill him while he was being strangled
crossbow but that has to be a perfect shot
and the heart or in the brain part or the
brain anything else is not gonna cut it don't
cut it hide it hiding bedroom bathroom loft
loft doesn't have any cover no doors to barricade
in his best case scenario he doesn't find
you and you bleed to death oh back outside
I've tried that once who knows you already
tried that once there's not a lot of room
to maneuver he figures out you're there
do the classic Horror DVD poster sooner or
later he is coming in here he knows I'm bleeding
out once he is in this house it is over he
is bigger stronger and faster harder better
aren't you Kanye me right now a death punching
you all right and we can't wait right you
go outside you're dead this is a really really
well done right now whoa yeah if you were
a better writer this wouldn't be happening
which means there's only one ending he won't
expect he can't run hide or wait you gotta
kill him and vitamin what does that leave
join him I'll kill him I said that first I
said kill him in the message I didn't know
which way they were vitamin for intimate dialogue
[__] oh hey there you want a cigarette
your kitty kitty is he gonna use her to try
to lure who's there there hurt the kitty welcome
home puss you're gonna see mommy very soon
in hell at least you'll see you ugh down to
the front oh yeah damn quality shot but that's
not killing it what what what ow oh [Music]
ah
ow oh my god oh
jeez oh I've actually never seen a hand that
mangled ever before in my entire life I feel
like I could vomit maybe one other time but
yeah oh
Gotten Good at picky hand gags lately in horror
Cinema
I'm coming in she did get him though he might
be bleeding too
come at me bro [Music] oh last remaining finger
to give you the bird
write him a message
[Music] [Laughter] I love her you think you're
so tough
hahaha
to finish my book if I died a day let this
be my last little Testament yes smart
ah
what an incredible ending wow
oh ugh
hold on [Music] oh whoa what what those are
glass shards
yeah gnarly but he's coming through the other
way yeah he just dropped into frame he's right
behind her maybe she knows this hi you know
what I feel his breath I think you're holding
out on me I bet if I hit the right spot I
can make you scream
you're one of those guys out this breath yes
yes oh my God
nice oh grab the other knife now here's the
job don't leave him with both of them grabs
the other night finish the job work the killer
bounce out to Tony Baker work hand is so effing
gnarly yeah and when I look at it I like can't
I get Phantom pains sympathetic pains yeah
I feel like I've been holding myself this
whole movie
oh oh
no she's pretending maybe I think she's just
exhausted
what was it it's like oh wow
clever girl this is good very good yeah yeah
yup yup yup I am obsessed with her
go for it [Applause] it's okay these things
are so disorienting
come on we're so close
pop is cork
wrist get him in the wrist maybe they're gonna
do the endings again oh [Music] oh
come on come on
with the pull out do you think they're both
gonna die right now God that has to be a unique
kind of pain
oh
if I were her that's like the proudest I'd
ever be in my whole life I mean yeah right
also she wrote that thing like show me the
money or give me the money whatever write
this story babe you end up rich yeah
you're back my phone who do you call resisting
the urge you call the cops Ghostbusters they
got help with this situation no you should
call us Craig that's who she called
the cops show up what the hell happened what
the hell happened here oh good that's right
she did uh hit him right in the nick of time
her hand that's gonna need so many surgeries
this is the bluest cop car
you got a little peace of mind
huh really good well done good job Mike Flanagan
and Katie Siegel she wrote it she co-wrote
it damn that's really cool wow wow that was
on team really really great work oh I dug
the heck out of that that was really cool
that was so oh he edited his wow yeah he did
he always added his own stuff I didn't even
know I think that's the thing yeah I think
that's a Mike Flanagan thing or at least a
lot of his stuff certainly you would think
with a script like this you kind of would
need to because there's so few words yeah
right he just kind of he wrote it and was
like I don't know what I'm doing yeah I'm
gonna write it so much of this has to be in
yeah in the in the choreography and then the
other careful assembly and editing did that
meet your expectations knowing some of Mike
Flanagan's other work yeah I mean you know
this this to me is like okay earlier Mike
Flanagan before you know stuff like Hill House
that that I know him the best for uh and I
thought it did nicely to play off of you know
you see this and and being familiar with some
of the advertising you're like oh there's
a home invasion sort of slasher movie and
I think they did a nice job to present to
themselves very much that way uh John Gallagher
Jr I wonder if he oh and Michael wait wait
wait John Gallagher Jr is was that Friday
night what is he from he's from Walmart what
is it I gotta look I got I think he did a
movie that a friend of ours wrote what is
it not mistaken uh uh uh the vanishing of
Sydney Hall is the name of that movie I don't
know about that one but I got Logan Lerman
I think I've met him before like I really
feel like I know know this oh 10 Cloverfield
Lane sure there you go exactly there you go
yeah that's what it is okay where's where's
the John actor from because I know I've seen
him too okay let's check it out we gotta find
all of this right now so uh he Michael uh
trucko trucko um okay I don't know any of
these hunter killer next he's been in a lot
of stuff but I I definitely recognize him
from something oh he was in the Midnight Club
also midnight mass all right so Wow Mike Flanagan
uses all the same over and over again oh he
was in disjointed that's what I know him from
did you watch that Netflix show disjointed
he was uh he owned the place next door and
they had a whatever oh he was great in that
okay yeah but yeah I like the way that this
like played off of what I came to expect from
knowing at least the trailer and and did a
thing where it's like I could like Mike Flanagan
certainly seems like you know one of the you
know current people you turn to for like a
good Stephen King quality thing or uh a good
um uh what is her name who wrote Hill house
uh you know either way I think you you turn
to him for those sort of Gothic more literary
feeling things and this was cool because it
had all those Pleasures you want out of a
home invasion slasher movie there are a lot
of things that do remind me of something like
the strangers but I also really appreciated
that um and I also thought of like you're
next as well and I like that this kind of
yeah deconstructs a little bit of the home
invasion the slasher but but does it in a
way where you know instead of resting on the
mystery of the mask and the iconography they
really just make it like a a real cat and
mouse two characters on either side of a wall
basically you know know trying to outwit one
another and and so yeah like by the end it
started out and I was like okay look I've
seen versions of this movie before and this
is doing it pretty well but by the end I was
like oh this is actually pretty neat like
you take off the Killer's mask right away
like he becomes a character and it's all about
sort of watching them you know back and forth
as they try to figure each other out and then
you have the additional element of of yeah
the limited uh you know sound and whatnot
and her not being able to hear and having
to be resourceful in different ways I'm super
with you on that he has not missed for me
yet like no I I'm very consistent I didn't
think this was going to be the first one to
miss but like you said it kind of has a basic
premise as opposed to some of his other ones
that have more layers he is to me I don't
know if other people talk about him this way
but he I know him for doing things in the
horror space but also um like religious horror
I would almost call it and this didn't have
that second element this was this wasn't like
um I've teen Hill House blind Manor midnight
mass and Midnight Club I love all four of
those for different reasons but they all have
like a second thing and this kind of just
is what it is so I was it's very straightforward
yeah so I was kind of curious okay because
it was his earlier work because he probably
didn't have as big of a budget because there's
not that many people in the cast am I gonna
just be underwhelmed by this but I wasn't
because the suspense is there the whole time
and the the way that they it was shot and
um how believable her character is Katie Siegel's
character is just so Maddie that's the character
how believable Maddie is because she's never
out fighting him she's never like you know
sometimes all of a sudden you'll see in these
movies there will then just be this person
who significantly smaller and less strong
just like sucker punch somebody and you're
like that's not how that would work here she's
outsmarting him and she's a novelist and so
at every turn even with the multiple endings
or whatever I'm just sitting there thinking
this is really smartly done oh that was so
good I really dug that yeah and they're not
making her unbelie they're not to me at least
and again I would be curious to hear what
you know a deaf viewer's take might be on
a movie like this but I feel like they haven't
uh gone so far as to make it like oh yeah
there's this like badass moment where she
like suits up and all of a sudden she can
hear and sense everything via vibrations in
there like you know they kept everything uh
really it felt like conscientious to her situation
and to you know the few assets she has at
her disposal being inside the house and having
that space to work with and then yeah really
having to kind of figure this guy out and
Yeah like her being a writer is another like
really Stephen King flourish but I really
like the way that they put uh her sort of
thought process on display and the way that
they you know had her Express in various different
ways and and use the range of um uh what's
her name Katie Siegel like her abilities um
but yeah I thought she really inhabited that
role really well and she's like a hard one
final girl because again like this has made
me think in in moments of something like again
the strangers or or you're next and your next
certainly has that thing where it's like the
heroine emerges as this badass and that's
really fun I haven't seen either and that's
it works for that movie they're worth a watch
okay um but yeah like this I thought like
was a real tooth and nail struggle and I thought
that while it's not like the deepest character
piece or whatever I always felt connected
to Maddie and I always you know was like really
in the intensity of the moment with her why
do you think they included Craig I think it's
just one of those things to give you a red
herring it's something to give her story a
little bit more just flavor because now you
know like okay she's got this relationship
that is you know clearly in the past but not
entirely could he be the killer could he be
somebody who's going to show up later and
maybe get killed uh yeah I think it's mostly
yeah just like a character beat slash red
herring and I mean for me like that worked
because I was sitting here going look quick
go show up me too I kept saying he's like
she's called him a couple times he's called
back a few times maybe he'll just get concerned
but yeah like it worked that he didn't show
up I wonder if there was ever a version of
the script in which he did but I feel like
it was enough to have John show up because
that was realistic his wife is missing yeah
it's like it makes a lot of sense and we'd
also I don't think we need as much of them
being like what's going on like you know him
showing up and them trying to have a scene
and you know that if that happens maybe something
about their relationship I mean like I trust
Mike Flanagan as a writer uh and and clearly
Katie Siegel's like Shepherd at this as well
so like if they had chosen to go that way
I feel like it could have been fine it could
work but I didn't think it needed it whatsoever
yeah I agree with you I I also think that
a lot of horror movies a lot of movies in
general have a really hard time knowing when
to end yeah and I when when she's sitting
on the porch and she sees the cop cars I was
like oh are we gonna have to do a jump to
like something else and it was like I don't
want to do that because this was this full
story she did it she made it like I don't
need to see her in the cast yeah I don't need
to see her with her sister later on like I
don't need to see any of those things yeah
she this was like a one Mission how does it
end and and the premise the setup of this
movie being that conversation of her writing
the novel not knowing how that ends yeah and
then this having kind of the perfect ending
yeah I thought was really just yeah perfectly
done perfectly done yeah it's it's it's the
exact right kind of ending for a story like
this that again is like it's got nice little
uh nuances that clearly demonstrate the care
that they've put into this but it's not trying
to be so deep and heavy that it's not appropriate
just to end on that sigh of relief like we
made it she's gonna be fine you know finally
help is coming that midnight mass what's it
called candidmo what's it called you see something
and then something else like it's like a reference
Easter egg was interesting too I wonder but
this was before that I think yeah yeah it
definitely must have been so uh I wonder then
if that was if they had already been he's
populating or whatever yeah I mean if it if
it showed up in this I have to imagine it
was something that's been on his mind for
a while and then yeah like with the success
of this and the success of other things like
Oculus and of course Hill house um yeah I
think through all that you know he probably
got to realize that dream project or whatever
yeah um yeah but that was cool when you spotted
that and even something like the Stephen King
novel that we see and I was like yeah paying
homage to all the other creepy creepy weirdo
yeah because this did nicely to be like what
if home invasion slasher movie but instead
of going schlock we go Stephen King about
it it's sort of like how I felt it's like
yeah you've got a writer you have the unique
I think the most you know unique aspect people
latched on to is the element of oh you have
a a person who can't uh hear the full spectrum
of everything around her and so that's going
to be you know both the positive and a negative
I love the way it came around at the end too
with fire alarm and using you know the directly
opposite you know uh uh you know state of
being for the two of them as like a weapon
in that moment I thought was like a cool beat
and and that we don't get too much of a deep
dive like I really liked watching uh uh your
boy as the killer guy because you don't get
a crazy deep dive explanation on him he doesn't
have some kind of Grudge that we know about
you know he is it is that strangest thing
of just like I'm just out here doing this
man and like to me you know again a great
explanation is great but also for a movie
like this I think it's appropriate sometimes
to just be like that's pretty horrifying because
sometimes again lots of stuff happens in the
world I'm not gonna say this is realistic
but you know some Prowler could just pop up
at your house in the woods and you know torture
you for a little while I feel like all the
explanation that I needed was the 13 tally
marks to me that was this is who he is this
is what he does this is Sport this is game
you know yeah it's that to me showed okay
so we're not gonna get a backstory this is
nothing to do with her he was not coming after
something specific this is not a robbery this
is the 13th kill on his list yeah and I love
that they included that one little moment
that just makes you know that's what's up
with this guy this is what he does and he
hasn't been caught yet and that's also what
makes her be like I have to type out those
notes yeah because if I because I'm if I die
more than likely 14 I needed to be the the
last one yeah that moment when she started
typing I got really teary-eyed because I think
that the the I went out like I died fighting
or whatever like your last thoughts that you
want your family to know yeah is like get
this mother effort and also I just so you
guys know I went down like the Baddie that
I am as opposed to like your family always
having to wonder what happened here you think
about like getting that note as a family member
and just yeah being horrified but also so
proud of somebody that that's what they did
I don't know that was a really bizarrely emotional
mode they don't have the presence to be like
this is my life I might be on the way out
not your two hands John yeah it was certainly
not so gross yeah that was a question I wonder
how they did that yeah they certainly at least
had a prosthetic for part of it the strong
hand child was there anything that was lacking
for you anywhere that you were like I really
wish that they had done this or this not really
yeah me neither no I mean this is one of those
ones where I remember at the time people like
oh my God this movie is so amazing and I'm
like yeah it's really good I really liked
it and I think it's really conscientiously
done I'm not like this is my favorite horror
movie but I'm like yeah this is solid it's
really well made it's it's thoughtful it's
got some nice flourishes it's well shot without
being like you know there's that one shot
where she goes to the door and you get that
big tilt and that's kind of you know like
an eccentric shot but it's not like a James
Wan movie which I like James Wan movies I
like his style but it's much more kinetic
and much more um you know sort of roller coastery
uh I thought this had the right amount of
that I really like the music I liked the use
of you know diegetic sound in and out going
from her perspective to then being able to
hear the environments and two I mean even
though in the studio it's not always easy
to deal with low light photography I liked
a lot of that stuff too so um well on that
note should we hush what's hush unless you
got anything else to tell the world just really
good it was really really great I'm glad that
we watched it that's the coolest thing about
doing this is that movies that I probably
because this was on Netflix and off of net
whatever that I probably never would have
gotten around to it I'm so glad that I did
I love seeing simple stories like this being
told brilliantly well and that's what story
told well and yeah and final thought yeah
spending that time with the Killer and really
making him a character and watching as he
like comes up with the story to tell to John
like I thought that stuff was really nice
because you have all the requisite like he's
not a Hulk he's not like teleporting around
he's not silent and he's off but in a more
like tangible way where you're just like he's
like kind of bored and he's like playing with
his food and he's like semi amused by this
stuff but you can tell like yeah like that's
that's an unhinged guy that could actually
exist you know yeah yeah it's a good impression
Well Ron joxie has done it again Ron jocks
he's done it again yeah that thank you for
watching hush with us you guys are awesome
thank you for being amazing rejects uh and
we will be back with drippy moist in the future
moist he'll be back and hey before we go on
WE shout out a patron they shot
shout out to Kevin smart listen Kevin here's
the deal number one you're smart you're smart
there's actually I don't want to live up to
anything better in the world you could be
than smart because then you could be all the
other things if you're smart you can be smart
enough to be kind you can be smart enough
to be good you can be smart enough to be great
true also because the Celtics just traded
away Marcus Smart and I love him so much and
so you share a last name yeah so now I just
needed that smart back in my life so that's
why it's super sexy shout out to you that's
a smart shout out there Roxy looking smart
today Boston and smash smash your wicked smack
Kevin
how do you like them apples Kevin oh I could
say it because I'm one of them it just is
the trashiest sounding accent ever I'm so
sorry to turn your beautiful floated one of
the sexiest accents on a thing I was reading
by Liars 100 of liars agree that's bad uh
but you're not bad you're not bad at all because
you're Kevin and you're smart you're Wicked
yeah Kevin and you're [__] smart I love
you buddy stay pledged